the doctors who are treating coronavirus
patients they have the medical expertise
to determine whether or not they should
prescribe hydroxy and many of them and
there are already clinical trials in
place looking at hydroxychloroquine so
should we finish in about a year why not
just let the science speak for itself
why are you promoting this drug not
rights or talking about the benefits I
want them to try it and it may work and
it may not work but if it doesn't work
it's nothing lost by doing it nothing
because we know long-term what I want I
want to save lives and I don't want it
to be in a lab for the next year and a
half as people are dying all over the
place their doctors already able to
prescribe it off lately
well undo the what you accomplished well
I'll tell you what I accomplished
we bought massive amounts of it
twenty-nine million doses of it we have
it coming from all of the labs we're
actually now doing it here because in
case it does work we want to have it and
we've given it to drug stores with we're
sending it all over FEMA's doing it
FEMA's doing it we're doing it through
different channels so many different
channels including the companies that
make it it's a very special thing now it
may not work in which case hey it didn't
work and it may work in which case it's
going to save a lot of lives now a lot
of people say if the people walking in
prior to getting it if they take it it
has a profound effect well maybe it
doesn't maybe it doesn't I don't want to
wait a year to have to find out and only
CNN would ask that question fake news go
ahead
you